let me pull up this clip here we have it
from end wokeness is the name of the
Twitter account yeah and it's this viral
clip from the proud family this tweet
has 7.2 million views so maybe what
Disney is doing with these ridiculous
cult shows is trying to get us to talk
about it promote it but let me play for
you this clip which is gonna it's it's
gonna numb your brain you're gonna be so
angry so uh let's just play Let's play
it I'm gonna try and make sure it's not
too loud to start but here we go
wait hold on up we switched the Audio I
got it I got it Let's uh switch the
audio over and then try again
[Music]
what's that supposed to mean do you know
what it means you're doing it right now
doing what being defensive about race
Robert D'Angelo wrote a whole book about
it read it yet again same
um cover and everything
my dad wouldn't even look at the diary
he said his people would never own
slaves how could he just dismiss me like
that white fertility oh brother Kwame
brother Kwame tell us about white
fragility there's brother Kwame he's
gonna teach the kids what's really going
on with critical race Theory twins right
there they actually show the book right
this is a Disney show and here's the
thing
the the two characters that are arguing
this is an interracial gay couple
the crazy thing about it is
we as adults who understand
psychological manipulation and Cults and
things like that certainly understand
that it is a fallacy to be like if you
are defensive therefore it proves it
like you literally can never defend it's
a paradox and that's what white
fragility is if you're a white person
someone still don't understand what it
means it means the idea is white people
are very fragile it's meant to insult
and insight an emotional response to
make you angry thus eliciting a reaction
that you can use to justify what you're
saying to others so an example of
scenario uh I let's say uh you accuse
Phil of being racist because he's white
and therefore Phil then says that's not
fair because you immediately interrupt
and say you are fragile which is an
insult to anybody right but here's what
happens the average person gets offended
by being called fragile and then you
turn to everyone say see look how angry
he's getting he's irrational it's
narcissistic personality disorder
Behavior one-on-one well but but
actually what they're writing about why
fragility is psychological manipulation
101. yeah but that's what the the kinds
of Minds that conjure this kind of
double speak and this is a this is
actually abuse if you were in a
relationship with a with a with a
partner and and they were like I don't
like that you said this this way and you
interjected and said you're being
fragile you you're abusing them because
you're not you're making a statement and
you're intentionally causing emotional
distress and then you're not allowing
them to respond and then when they do
respect respond you're taking their
response as a great as an act of
aggression and therefore you're abusing
them emotionally the the white fragility
boils down to any attempt at explaining
why you reject racism is proof you are
racist
that's what white fragility is meant to
represent it's ridiculous and you're
exactly right it is manipulation it's
abuse and the that's the that's the
entirety of the the
I'm trying to think the best way to word
it it's the entirety of critical
theories when applied in well it's
Praxis I guess they call it but it's
it's the entirety of critical theories
when applied to to Everyday Life you
look for a way to make the power Dynamic
make you know make yourself a a victim
in the power Dynamic and then you use
that against the person you're talking
to whether it be race or whether it be
LGBT issues or whether it be feminism
it's always a manipulation yeah and you
can see how destructive this is because
you hear the voice of I guess this
couple's daughter being like my dad
wouldn't even look at this like how
could he be this way so you're just
sowing seeds of doubt in this already
complicated family and she has a it's
both of her dads they're an interracial
gay couple so now she has one dad who is
speaking correctly and one dad who's
actually racist so here's the other
thing like if you're in an interracial
couple and your partner fears like this
why did you get married and have a kid
you know like if you feel like your
white partner is racist how can you get
to the aisle but but we should get
married and we should have a life
together but not even that how can you
assume your gay white partner is racist
if he's marrying you yeah well that's
like the I mean
AOC like all these everybody you know
yeah yeah they all aoc's boyfriend hold
on he is as ginger as it comes if I
remember correctly he is he represents
the white person and all the white
person jokes he does I don't know I
don't even know what he looks like but I
find it I find it wildly comical you
know when the George Floyd riots happen
I I posted a picture of me so my my in
my old Instagram was deleted right and I
posted a picture holding a blue line
flag in whatever City in front of like
20 000 people and I I wrote this whole
thing about I don't you know I'm like
I'm against police brutality but I don't
need my white friends to feel I don't
need white people to be ashamed of being
white that doesn't cure racism and most
of what CRT does is not about equality
it's and this is what's gone wrong with
so much of the leftist ideology whether
it's whether it's critical race Theory
or lgbtq rights or the people are and
feminism Third Way feminism people are
not fighting for equality they're
fighting for Advantage yeah and it's
hard to all these any of these issues
it's hard to even address seriously
anymore because it's so blatantly
they can't put it on adults and
now they're transcribing and attacking
children and and families are gonna like
how do you even have this conversation
with your kid there's the intent there's
a saying that everybody's dealt a
different hand and it's about how you
play the cards so some people get good
cards some people get bad cards but you
got to make the best of it the funny
thing is you know I I'm gonna use a
bunch of Poker analogies in the next
couple of weeks because I've been
playing hold them quite a bit but I was
playing this past weekend some dude won
a massive pot with the worst possible
hand you could have seven he had seven
two off suit he bluffed his way into it
you can get bad cards but if you play
the game right if you know people you
can figure it you can figure it out well
I mean that's also representative of the
American dream this is part of the
deterioration of the ideology that if I
can make it here I can make it anywhere
right like we were talking about this
before we went on air right some of my
backstory is like my mother was a
crackhead I was abandoned as a baby I
have a twin brother my twin brother's in
jail doing 20 years for trying to murder
me right we he he's a he got high on
Dust broken in my apartment in 2010 I
came home he tried to kill me I've been
sober 14 years we both had a lot of
problems growing up we both grew up
hanging on the streets we were both drug
dealers I chose music and then
ultimately I chose recovery and he chose
to go a different path that's what life
is life is about choices right and so I
I'm somebody who you know
I I I know the power of making decisions
and and owning your decisions and that
your life is basically where your life
is going to go in America is based on
how much responsibility you take on
yourself and this stuff that it
continuously promotes self-victimization
and what happens to people who
continuously victimize themselves they
never achieve anything they stay
miserable and they look for someone else
to blame and you can get in a cycle of
doing this your whole life will go by
and you'll never do anything right I
call them Barstool astronauts right
because that's what they do they I could
have been a I could have been a Salesman
oh it's a tough job you know it's like
obvious foreclosers and it's beyond race
right because how is it that
how is it that I was able to come from
where I came sell millions of Records
play on Arenas you know make friends all
over the world have people love me
little kids singing my songs and and you
know I I take care of my mother I
financially take care of my whole family
right and so
I don't want to lose that and I don't
like this I don't like this messaging
for African Americans I don't like it
for any Americans because it's a lie
it's fundamentally teaching white people
are bad and and and African-American
people and minorities can never make it
in this country because of white people
no that's not true yeah look at every
basketball player look at every rapper
rap is the biggest most popular selling
music not on the halftime show yeah the
Big Show everybody's watching the most
expensive commercials and it's Rihanna
yeah like I mean look I get it this
country uh things used to be very racist
and the 50s weren't that long ago a lot
of people alive today lived through that
stuff and then you have other countries
which are still extremely racist because
that's the world but hey man the US is
one of the least racist places on the
planet if not it is the least racist
it's the most tolerant right you know
it's like I've seen people you know when
when
you know Israel and Palestine started
firing at each other and I'm not even
going to get into my stance on that but
what I saw online was they were like
lgbtq for free Palestine and I was like
if you go there yeah you'll die yeah
like
they might kill you you can't go there
right I met a I met a guy who said that
Donald Trump is the least racist
president this country has ever had yeah
and I thought that was funny and I was
like even Obama and he was like oh yeah
and I'm like it's kind of weird because
Obama's you know half black but he
explained like U.S policy and how things
are changing and how you end up with
Trump and he says like no I think
Trump's racist but like the least we've
ever had and he was basically explaining
like yo he's like we had presidents who
owned slaves man come on it's not it's
not it's not a high bar it's easy for
Trump to be the least racist president
and this is a guy who didn't like Trump
but the point is yeah we're we're making
things better all the time this is the
opposite of that the white fragility
stuff is racial tension yeah the hands
up don't shoot stuff the black lives
matter stuff is all making things worse
and I think they want that I think
Democrats will be Democrats and and
leftists want it because it allows them
to sow chaos well BLM has also been
hijacked right like I was on a podcast
last year on um Andy frisella's Show
with Hawk Newsome who him and his sister
started the BLM in New York
and it was originally to address the
issue of police brutality against black
men he's not he's not allowed in the
organization they don't he's not allowed
no me no black men are allowed to hold
position within the BLM Corporation
unless you're a trans man the people
that are yeah the people yeah and
they're you're not allowed to say this
because they'll come for you the people
that are most affected by violence from
police which is what BLM was started to
address the people that are most
affected by it are young black men I
mean who are not allowed to have a job
in that Corporation yeah yeah and yeah
well I mean it's all hijacked by
leftists the whole project the the
entirety of the project is about leftism
and not helping the most vulnerable
people or the the group of people that
need the the the the help from black
lives matter the most it is totally and
completely ideological and has nothing
to do with trying to help young black
men who are the most the the most most
victimized uh group when it comes to
police brutality do you think there's
any way to turn black lives matter
around do you think you could ever bring
it back to being an organization it's
like making McDonald's not about Burgers
but we have to ask the question right I
just think there needs to be I think
they're trying to do that actually
Donald sells salads I mean I I think
they chicken fish I think that no
McDonald's will never be healthy
so will black lives matter be effective
I don't know it's original founding I
guess I should say I don't think that uh
look I think that the leftists right
what and this is a this is all
Republicans need to hear this and
understand this because this is where
Republicans fail they fail at culture
what the leftists are great at they're
they're branding manipulation is
impeccable yeah so they understand the
key is to taking an unattackable
position and then using it as a cloak
for their for communism or Socialism or
or authoritarianism right because
everything's under the banner of
Tolerance of of these like
feigning false positive things right you
know you can't call us bad guys we just
said we're not anti-bad guys yeah yeah
we black lives matter yeah obviously
right the sky is blue like okay water is
wet right yes you're against us you're
against us we all agree yeah but the but
then if you're but that's the thing too
people say oh you can't be racist if
you're black I'm like well as someone
who is Black who went against an
organization I've never been called the
n-word so much of my life
by other black people who are mad that I
pointed out that the money that was
being raised was not going it's not the
friendcast let me tell you I have caught
a couple of hard ones in the homies I
have not seen
people at a conservative rally
shout the n-word at anybody but I have
seen on numerous occasions ant white
anti-fascists anti-focus black police
officers no and people oh really yeah
the the story I often tell in in
Portland where there was a black proud
boy and all they were all screaming
downward at him and there and and I was
just like holy I can't believe right now
I'm standing in Portland
at this guy yeah there's only three
black people in the whole city it's
crazy when I went there they all were
like hey just so you know we're on we're
the only three cool things bro you're
number four you know I was just passing
through
like I was nuts man they got one of them
they got one third of them
this is what I see I I saw this in
Sweden too a bunch of white people
majority claim that they're not racist
and then they do things to prove they're
not racist while enacting policy that is
extremely racist or pushing policies or
other things that are that are racist
yeah I mean I don't know I don't know
about what what is that an example of is
that to deal with the Syrian and
refugees so Sweden's got multiple
problems they've got uh Somalian
refugees in the 90s and they've got
Afghanistan
afghanistani refugees and so and syrians
now as well I don't think syrians was
that as much I was there in November
there's some stuff there's there were
syrians when I was there a few years ago
it is a lot of people from Afghanistan
and the the problems that people refer
to in Sweden are the children of the
Somali refugees from the 90s so what the
swedes did was they were like we're not
racist we're going to bring all these
people in and then shove them all into
ghettos yeah it didn't integrate them at
all which created France did the same
thing right right it just creates
Belgium because what they're they're
like we're not racist but you can't live
near me and push them all out yeah but
that's the not in my backyard thing
there's multiple issues with that stuff
too it's like sir you know there are
certain countries that they move you
know they move to a place and then they
don't acclimate right and then they have
start gangs and there's criminality and
rape and all this other stuff that some
these countries are like we're they
don't even know how to deal with it you
know so it's that's that's a whole other
issue in and of itself thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time